[Music]
even on the show weeds for a number of
years seven years 27 years can't believe
you guys got on the air that had not
late 50s no we uh marijuana but it's
been eight seasons it's been eight
season and that's a lot of pop well
here's things gonna ask you about I've
known you for a long time we used to
work together back it's darn alive and
you never seemed to me like the kind of
guy that would even try pot so and then
you're you're playing this character who
of course absolutely loves it because I
got his character but the thing is I
like to be alert Conan like right now I
know Andy's right there yeah if I was
stoned I wouldn't know where he was
right there right but um so you don't
smoke poppies you won't be alert exactly
I don't do a lot of I don't do drugs
really at all I I did try ecstasy once
though but only as a breath mint and
guess what you're really strong yeah I
have no complaints like eight hours
nothing nothing and I've never done coke
in my life really lately I have been
offered tons of coke back in the 80s and
90s you had all these comedy clubs and
at the time I had a very bad self-image
and they would always bring it out on a
mirror and I don't want to see myself if
they brought it out like on a breadboard
I probably a cokehead
well do you have any wild side at all is
there a wild side to Kevin Nealon um you
know what I have these fantasies of
having a wild side like I want to get a
tattoo eventually yeah I don't know what
I'll get it won't be a [ __ ] like a
[ __ ] stamp you wouldn't get a [ __ ] now
no that's for girls okay great do you
have you don't have a [ __ ] I do not
have a [ __ ] it's just for girls trans
roles they get the butterflies and stuff
done I was gonna get a [ __ ] stamp I
probably get a that's a tough question
I didn't ask I know you did
it's funny how people ask their own
questions that's be great if do I like
Conan O'Brien yes I do
do I like Andy not so much no I I
probably get if I was gonna get a [ __ ]
stamp I probably get like extra belt
loops or something something yeah that's
sensible but you know if you're a 21
year old girl you want to [ __ ] stamp
don't get it on your lower back here get
behind your neck because eventually your
skin's gonna sag all the way down here
back because if you get it on your lower
back to begin with very soon it's gonna
become a taint stash for guys and in
that case you should get like a back
because it's gonna be hanging upside now
friction and that my friend is my wild
side let's talk about the so about your
summer did you did
he gets a fist bump I get now right good
all right thank you
summer did you travel during the study
to get doing any going anywhere do it
everything that's a good question yeah I
actually asked yeah you should call your
own questions yes he went to Polynesia
yeah um let me have him all right Harry
answers I went to Polynesia no I I want
to what I'm gonna do is I want to go to
Germany with my friend but here's one
ago because he's Jewish and the whole
Holocaust thing I just cuz I want to go
to German he doesn't want to go and but
I think in life you have to let go of
things sometimes just let it go I said
why don't you come with me when we're
there you can Kira Sadie's there you're
even right then even the score and then
all the people are just plain happy in
life like I was in New Zealand actually
Andy and I were New Zealand ago doing a
movie aliens in the Attic the kid and
people there were very happy yeah they
weren't have fun they just they throw
themselves off the bridges with the
bungee cords you're big into bungee they
love that kind of action right you know
what I mean even when they have a baby
there now they don't cut the umbilical
cord like a month maybe then his hands
freeze yeah get a lot more done sure it
gets tangled up in your laces you know
but still yeah